while the cast of waco is universally
great the actor tasked with portraying
david koresh frequently steals the show
that actor is Taylor Kitsch and while
he's all but unrecognizable in the role
you've absolutely seen his face before
as an actor Kitsch has been around for a
couple of decades now and has built an
impressive acting resume that resume
includes a memorable stint in one of
HBO's most critically adored shows
unfortunately that stint ended up coming
in the season of the series that critics
liked the least the show in question is
of course HBO's anthology crime saga
true detective which premiered to rave
reviews in the winter of 2014 behind the
work of Matthew McConaughey Woody
Harrelson and series director Carrie
Joji Fukunaga sadly none of those
talented individuals returned for true
detectives second season instead series
creator NIC pizzolatto conjured up a new
tale of cops and criminals for the
show's second run of episodes in doing
so he also put together a seriously
impressive cast to bring those stories
to light with Rachel McAdams Colin
Farrell Vince Vaughn Kelly Reilly and
more joining Kitsch for the series
second go-round it could have gone
better
with such a stacked cast season two may
well have provided too much of a good
thing for Pitt Salado and his writing
team as they struggled through an
underwhelming tragically unfocused run
of episodes overstuffed with too many
characters and narrative entanglements
though kitchens character Paul wood drew
was frequently at the center of the
seasons melodrama he was just as
frequently among its more interesting
individuals coping with a treasure trove
of personal anguish and inner demons
that would have been enough for an
entire season of television in and of
themselves
like many up-and-coming actors Taylor
hitches early years were spotted with
supporting roles opposite bigger names
like many young actors Taylor Kitsch was
once gifted a coveted role in an
aspiring blockbuster with full-on
franchise potential and like so many
young aspiring superstars before him
things didn't quite work out to be fair
that doesn't have much to do with Kitsch
himself the truth is there are not many
people in or out of showbiz who could
tell you exactly what went wrong with
Disney's 2012 tent pole John Carter it
had all the makings of a surefire
family-friendly crowd-pleasing hit
till it got released when John Carter
finally hit theaters in 2012 it did so
behind a middling critical response and
crippling word-of-mouth with the film's
unintentional kam penis most frequently
mentioned as its biggest problem not
surprisingly the film which is nowhere
near as bad as you've heard became one
of the biggest box-office bombs in
Disney history claiming just north of 73
million dollars at u.s. box offices
barely recouping its mammoth budget with
its worldwide take of just over 284
million dollars though it's quite likely
you've seen kitchen one of his
big-screen rolls over the years it's far
more likely you recognize him from his
early days on television Kitsch did
after all feature prominently in one of
the best-loved dramas of the 2000s one
that also proved small screen
adaptations of big-screen successes
aren't always doomed to failure based on
the 2004 film of the same name the TV
show in question is NBC's rousing sports
drama Friday Night Lights if you somehow
slept on the book the movie and the
series Friday Night Lights follows the
travails of a coach and the players of a
powerhouse football program in a small
Texas town among Friday Night Lights
young cast for future stars like Jesse
Plemons Adrianne Palicki and Michael B
Jordan Taylor Kitsch also appeared in 68
of the show's 76 episodes as the roguish
star running back Tim Riggins if we are
being too bold we'd say he was
frequently brilliant on the series
imbuing his stoic character with natural
charisma and hard-earned wisdom even as
he was frequently boozing it up and
generally running amuck all over town of
course if you do recognize Kitsch from
one of his big screen ventures it's
entirely likely that venture came in is
better than the film turn as gambit in
2009's dreadful x-men origins Wolverine
if you happen to recognize kitsch from
another movie however it may well be for
his hilarious appearance in the samuel
l.jackson starring horror tinged camp
fest the world came to know as snakes on
a plane if you managed to miss kitsch in
the film it's because he wasn't actually
in snakes on a plane for very long in
fact his Randy newlywed was one of the
first characters to die fortunately it
was far from the last we'd see of kitsch
as his Waco performance indicates he has
plenty more left in the tank check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are come
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]